you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is Game five
from the 2013 World Chess Championship
match between Anand and Carlsen going
into this round both players remain
level at two points each and Carlsen on
the white end of this one opened with c4
Anand replies be six and we enter the
Queens gambit declined c6 indicates the
semi Slav and efore indicates the
Marshall gambit which really isn't a
gambit at all if white so chooses after
D takes Knight takes we have Bishop
check and this is where we could enter a
gambit line if white plays Bishop d2
where the idea here is to give up upon
in exchange for having the bishop pair
but we don't have that
it's instead Knight c3 the material that
remains balanced and now the immediate
strike at the white center quite useful
as well to the queen nine eight three
black doesn't give up the bishop pair so
easily maintaining the pin both the
Knights come out and we have Bishop e3
more development maybe one day there is
the option to capture on c5 and win upon
but there's always the drawback of
capturing on c3 and reply to it which
would have a situation where White has
an extra pawn but triple isolated see
pawns and that I'm not so sure that
that's a good road to go down
so knight c6 queen d3 is there to watch
over the knight also addresses the
possibility for let's say the knight to
post up on e4 which would add more
pressure to the pinned piece so queen d3
it is C takes D Knight takes D in an
important moment I believe is this one
here where anon chose Knight G form
there was an option to first tie in with
this Knight g4 idea the move Knight e5
which will kick the Queen away from the
defense of the bishop you don't want to
go here because of
Nighy for so most natural and probably
best is Queen c2 and then what could
follow is night here looking to take the
bishop and this would have been an
interesting line with B for Bishop to c7
or maybe not even the reaction right
away probably you can take make sure you
get the bishop pair and damage the white
structure and then return back to c7 now
that this might seem all well and good
and because the night is on e5 a nice
home black having the bishop pair and
the queen is ready to come out I guess
as a positive for white keep in mind
these these Pun there is a majority on
the Queen side in favor of white but I
don't believe that this is going to
really be enough for white I believe
this is an opportunity that black had
right here on this move 11 but we didn't
have Knight to e5 this move was not
inserted and instead Knight on Knight to
g4 was played right away and as the
follow up we had queenside castle and
now the capture on e3 with the pawn
recapturing as otherwise this is turning
out to be a very uncomfortable pin to
get out of so one other detail and one
interesting line after queenside castle
would have been to actually capture on
d4 and after it's recaptured to play e5
after Bishop c5 you exchange Queens and
the idea here is to now do what to try
your best to crash through on f2 the
bishop is tethered to its defense so
what about kicking away this Bishop with
b6 well black needs to be careful our
white needs to be careful Bishop b4 and
now the rook is hit and if you move the
rook you're dead this is game over for
white not checkmate but you're losing a
ton of material so you don't do that
after Bishop b4 what we would have is
the capture
and after takes on a eight you take the
night and at the end of it you can take
the pond and this is actually turning
out to be a very draw a line but an
interesting one nevertheless where we
have the night finally getting picked
back up the king bumps up hitting the
bishop and again a very dry type of line
that we are seeing here black is
probably a little bit better but we
don't go down that road it's a very long
winded road right there with capturing
on d4 and then following up a five a lot
of calculation needed in that particular
line but instead it was capturing on e3
knowing that you are picking up the
bishop pair and damaging the white pawn
structure it's got to be pretty good but
we will soon see because there are still
some issues on the black end white a
single move away moving the bishop to be
fully developed black still needs some
time in order to complete development
castles get the Queen out get the bishop
out and there might be some tactical
vulnerabilities due to the white rook
being opposite the black Queen so from
here we have the bishop drop back and
now Knight takes on c6 after its
recapture we have the Queen's come off
one other interesting try might have
been to keep the Queen's on centralize
the Queen this seems very appealing pawn
is hit Queen is hit and the Queen is
also around to watch over a vulnerable
point e v Bishop d7 would be needed and
this also seems like a nice follow-up
putting pressure on d7 and g7 but there
is a good response in that of e5 and
black will be able to neutralize things
in this variation with Queenie 7 so
while it looks pretty appealing to go
down this road where you play Queen to
d4 I'm not so sure it's really amounting
to much what would maybe be best is to
simply develop at that point but
nevertheless we enter a variation where
the Queen's are exchanged Carlsen
takes on d8 and then follows up with
trying to get the bishop on this
diagonal kingi seven struck me as quite
odd and this was an interesting line
that I saw when reviewing for this video
during the game I was thinking about
Bishop g5 and it seems really really
appealing to attack upon that's
unprotected and to also place it in a
pin I was fixated on this idea where the
rook had to defend like so but
surprisingly enough white can ignore the
threat on e3 and play Bishop f3
generating some threats of his own allow
the pawn to be captured and now it's
still how do you solve the pressure
against this pun if the bishop is
playing here keep in mind that white can
add additional fuel to this c6 pawn and
try to exploit the fact that the bishop
on b7 is unprotected by playing this
pawn up to b5 and on top of that there
is also this idea let's say the bishop
plays here there's the idea of sinking
this Knight into the d6 square so there
was so there will certainly be
compensation for white giving up the
pawn in that particular line and it's
something that I completely overlooked
so nevertheless it was not Bishop g5 but
rather King II 7 it's quite common to
not want to castle at this moment and
keep the King centralized and Castle
artificially Bishop f3 is no surprise
Bishop d7 again is I think aimed at
keeping the Bishop - on a square where
he is at least protected and not
tactically vulnerable to these types of
pawn marches to be 5 so it's Bishop d7
the knight gets rolling on e4 on two
squares on c5 and d6 c5 is played and
now we have a few in between moves
played within these next moves
coming up f-five undermining the defense
of c-5 this is all a very forest line C
takes the F takes E and now not the
immediate recapture but you play first
b7 you're going to lose this pawn anyway
and why not play b7 what does this
accomplish well it makes sure that these
pawns will remain split it's much better
for black if white takes right away then
these these pawns are together and much
more healthy so b7 interferes with this
idea it was played in a blink rook to b8
and only then you recapture on e4 and so
too does black regain that pawn so as it
stands right now in this endgame how
exactly to assess it white is the side
from here on out who's always a little
bit better and will be the one who's
trying to press for the win the main
indicate indicator for that assessment I
believe is due to the bishop on e4 very
dominant position hitting all parts of
the board
whereas this bishop is quite passive
you'll note that this rook is already on
an open file and not long enough this
rook is on the is going to occupy the
other hope and file and on top of this
we also have the bishop applying
pressure to h7 which means the rook will
have to or black will have to work a
little bit harder before the rook in the
corner can be become activated so from
here getting all pieces working rook on
H to f1 this rook in this game is very
active raking now the fifth-ranked
possibilities for giving check to the
King possibilities for coming over to e5
where would attack the Bishop and pawn
rook F for preparing to double on the F
file it is accessible to pawn strikes
and we do see that right away with g5
there is also a 5 and you do need to be
careful about where exactly you retreat
your rook but you'll note that this move
I believe is shy too
a from because a nun wants to reserve
the option for the rook to pivot on the
e5 square so it is instead the move g5
attacking the rook back to f3 and this
is well this is not the most natural of
squares I thought rook f2 but rook f3
well rook rook I'm sorry rook to f2 I
think is most natural but the purpose
behind rook f3 is to meet this
possibility where when the bishop is
attacked if he moves away at least you
are there to defend the pawn on III and
if the rook is kicked away notice how
you could always step up here and this
is a good exchange for white if this did
if this did take place taking on e
taking on G this was an unhealthy pawn
and white took a perfectly healthy black
pawn not a good trade for black so we
didn't go down that road it was instead
rook f3 we didn't see rook c5 but rather
h5 gets it out of the bishops view and
now the fruit the rook is freed up to
move white doubles on the F file and
black is simply there to stop the rooks
from penetrating on the seventh rank but
the deeper purpose behind this doubling
on the F file is to restrict this rook
notice how the bishop doesn't have
really any moves it's devoted to
defending f7 it can't make use of g6 so
there's some entangling that black needs
to do and it all it is all to try and
activate the rook that's in the corner
the rook that's on b5 it's difficult to
get that rook much more active so Bishop
c2 backing up and this this is also
paving the way for this pond to advance
and take away this key Square d5 so that
eventually the white king could be
entering the center of the board without
having to worry about a rook check on
the D file but eventually what we will
see is that black does in fact make use
of the D file with the
to give check to the white king so first
it's rook to f6
not my initial instinct for sure after
this move the bishop is pinned my first
idea is get out of the pin but the move
that was played is rook to f6 that
certainly does what it prevents the
bishop from coming to g6 to pile up on
this pinned piece so about eight minutes
was invested on that particular move and
it's a very active one watching over g6
and should this rook get active a little
bit later if he moves off of this corner
square a new square is available to this
rook namely h6 h4 is aimed at developing
the bishop I don't know if I should say
develop but the bishop wants to move so
that the rook can finally have some
other options not that he wants to go to
the corner but the d8 square in
particular so that's what it's doing
it's vacating h5 maybe it's doing more
but that I believe that that is the
primary function of this h4 move efore
is played the King can now rely upon the
D to square a little bit more without
fear of a check a5 is played I believe
to lock down on these pawns from
advancing here comes the king the rook
gives an attack to this pun and we have
b3 if you go to c3 we just end up having
these sorts of things a little back and
forth sort of situation so it's simply
b3 and eventually white will like to
have a role reversal here in the form of
the King coming over to watch over the
pond which would then free up the bishop
ideally I think this Bishop would like
to get on this diagonal where'd a
watches over the pawn on B 3 but also
puts pressure on e6 for a second time
and that will be quite difficult to me
but Anand is not so quick to allow that
with Bishop h5 this rook is now ready to
be activated with check and we will see
that soon enough
first king c3 the rook gives a check and
after King to b2
rook to d8 at first glance I thought
hang on you better be careful about
moving this rook away I thought as soon
as it plays to d8 the rook is going to
come over here to put pressure on the
bishop what would happen if that was
played big trouble for white white is
all of a sudden lost you have to crawl
up into a ball to defend this bishop
it's still not enough bishop d1 this is
game over these rooks have a lot of fun
bunch of little checks thrown in pick
your favorite way to win at this point
game over black will end up winning that
so that's the main threat is what I'm
getting at there's no time for rook h6
simply defend rook to F 2 is there
securing your second rank
now comes rook d4 more active to rook
lifts after the rook came here and
picked up the pond what did he do there
was a rook lift on b5 functioning now in
the fifth rank similarly what is black
doing gets to an open file now functions
on a rank so both the fourth and fifth
ranks are occupied they're being
patrolled right now by these black rooks
very active on ranks as well as files
although this one here is not the
longest of files rook h6 now comes and
Bishop d1 as a reply very cute move to
be seeing placing this bishop deep in
the white position its intention is to
eliminate the bishop so that this rook
can finally crash through on e4 Carlsen
avoids that the bishop wants to stick
around to watch over efore and now black
piles up on this pawn and how exactly to
meet this threat I mean you could defend
b3 but again you are then dropping e4 so
fortunately there is this timely King
move King c3 there's no time to take b3
there's a thread on the rook and on top
of that move what else is it doing when
the King plays up to see three it is
vacating b2 so that it could be defended
on the next turn so black addresses the
threat on the rook with c5 and now
Carlsen
falls into a ball with rook to be two
very timely move and how exactly to now
break out the b3 pun well what we have
is first 'if I've and then rook to g6
applying pressure to this pun and this
is keep in mind the times that you're
seeing on the right are at least some
indication of where the players were
during the game and at this point Anand
still needed to make move 39 and move 40
before an additional hour is added to
his clock and it is at this point move
39 that I believe there is a mistake the
move a4 is likely not best and before I
get into the actual game I think it was
g4 where there would be the line Bishop
to d3 black can capture on b3 and not
take on b3 with the King because you
would drop the bishop instead rook takes
g4 now since the bishop is no longer
there to defend and then h3 giving up
this pond and playing through from this
particular position which is quite a
difficult line to be seen especially
with such little time remaining before
time control so we didn't see that it
was not the move g4 but rather a for
cracking at the b3 pawn for now at third
time Carlsen picks up the Jeep on an on
grabs the B pun with check to recapture
and on top of that now we have Carlson
grabbing on e5 with check King d6 is the
only move in order to also defend the
pawn on c5 and now the rook comes over
to attack the H bomb looking to win now
a second pun Carlsen at this point is up
upon and it's a difficult road ahead for
Anand what was tried
is rook to d1 and first we have this
check interesting to see in this game in
this game many moments where you think
that you have to immediately respond to
these threats but there are there have
been multiple in between moves and this
is just another one of them E 5 is
played with check which is now clearing
the way so that the bishop has some new
possibilities King d5 the bishop now
gets out of the way and is in a position
to give check to the king you want to
question that Kings position in the
center of the board
Bishop to h7 does just that black throws
in a check the King is decentralized for
just a little bit but it's still there
to maintain pressure on b3 so that when
this check comes white will end up
picking up the a pond and that's what we
do have rook G one Bishop check the
bishop is not captured right away this
is another instance of not making an
immediate capture but addressing this
Kings position we saw something similar
in game 4 where Anand had his white rook
on the c8 square and he could have taken
on e8 there was a bishop there at the
time but instead he first gave a check
to Carlson's King and only then came
over to e8 to pick up the bishop but we
have that being returned this thing the
same idea is present in this game giving
a check kicking the King away from the
center and only then taking on b3 now
how is this a little bit different
you'll note if you immediately capture
takes takes the King is just a single
step away from getting to d5 but much
different now after you first insert
this check on h6 the King is two squares
away from getting to this central post
so give a check the King goes to d7 you
take the bishop then and then take the
pawn on h4 Carlson has now
three three two one advantage and from
here it's actually just a matter of
technique in carlson is very efficient
with how exactly to proceed simply
pushing this past pond this is a nice
move rook h7 is saying that i will in
fact do two things one get my pawn to a7
- it will be defended and maybe i could
add a little bit more it will make sure
that the black king will never be
allowed to to guard the a8 square if
there is a rook on h7 here and upon his
on a7 there's no way for the king to
guard the a8 square and so what this
means for black is that their rook will
be the one who's responsible to stopping
the pond from promoting so what stride
is first king d5 preparing to give a
check the pond continues to march black
gets behind the past on it gets as far
as it can came to c5 and simply white
with this move here is reminding black
that they have yet another past pond and
it is at this point that Anand resigns
and we have our first decisive game in
this 2013 World Chess Championship match
the idea here in this game would be to
simply move the pawn up as far as you
can keep the RIP right where it is and
then get out of the way and advance a
bit more the H pond to h8 there's no way
for the black rook to prevent both pawns
from queening so as it stood in this
game after just this h4 move it is again
Anand resigning this Game five and we
now go into Game six where Anand will
have the white pieces and in game 7 the
colors will switch and so Anand will
also have white in game 7 and I'll keep
in mind from the previous World
Championship match where it was
Anand versus gelfand Anand lost Game
seven but what did he do he came right
back in game eight in a historical way a
very short game he won against Delfin
and I think 17 moves something under 20
moves so we will see what happens next
as it stands right now Carlson has three
points Anand has two and we will see
what happens in Game six so that's all
for this video as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye
[Music]